[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo América por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañera Natalia Plaza
Natalia qué tal Buenos días Andrés
Natalia vamos a empezar hablando de los
avances en la ciencia sobre relojes
inteligentes que pueden ayudar a
detectar el parkinson con años de
anticipación de acuerdo a un nuevo
estudio de investigadores británicos sí
Andrés es un estudio de investigadores
de la Universidad de cardif en Reino
Unido y esta ha sido publicado en la
revista nature medicine Los
investigadores utilizaron la
Inteligencia artificial para analizar
datos recogidos por relojes inteligentes
en total se reunieron datos de más de
100.000 personas que estaban reunidos en
el biobanco de Reino Unido esto es una
base de datos de salud pública que está
justamente a disposición de este tipo de
investigaciones el estudio analizó
analizó patrones de acelerometría esto
quiere decir analizar los movimientos
los patrones de movimientos y de vi que
hacen las personas en su día a día y lo
hicieron durante el lapso de una semana
Los investigadores detectaron que había
pequeños movimientos que desarrollan las
personas que a largo plazo acaban
desarrollando parkinson por poner
algunos ejemplos son pequeños
movimientos como tardar más tiempo
pulsando las teclas de un teléfono
cuando se envía un mensaje de chat o
escribir con letra más pequeña Estos son
pequeños movimientos como decíamos
Andrés que son imperceptibles para las
personas Pero que sin embargo no pasan
desapercibidos para los sensores que
están instalados en los en los relojes
inteligentes entonces sin duda Es una
herramienta que puede resultar
revolucionar y en el campo de la
medicina y que pueda ayudar a muchas
personas a que desarrollen a que no
desarrollen parques Sí el estudio lo que
ha detectado es que con estos datos se
puede predecir hasta con 7 años de
anticipación que una persona podría
llegar a tener riesgo de desarrollar
parkinson actualmente cuando se detecta
la enfermedad desafortunadamente
normalmente los síntomas son ya muy
evidentes recordemos que esta vez una
enfermedad neurodegenerativa y que sus
síntomas son síntomas muy fuertes como
lentitud de movimientos que cada vez son
progresivos y cada vez son causan más
dificultad como lentitud de movimientos
rigidez dificultad para coordinarse o
temblores Incontenibles hasta el momento
recordemos también que es una enfermedad
que no tiene cura los medicamentos que
hay hasta el momento son para paliar los
síntomas y hay en estos momentos también
medicamentos que están intentando frenar
a largo plazo que se que se que vaya
degenerando la enfermedad pero hasta el
momento ningún medicamento lo ha
conseguido lo que dicen los
investigadores en las conclusiones de
este estudio es que a largo plazo el
hecho de poder detectar con anticipación
que una persona tiene riesgo de
desarrollar parkinson podría dar más
tiempo a la medicina una vez ya existan
medicamentos para frenar los avances de
esta enfermedad Y así también dar mucho
más tiempo a las personas
sin embargo también ha habido reacciones
de expertos al estudio que dicen que
también Abre una discusión ética
importante debido a que las personas
podrían saber con hasta siete años de
anticipación que podrían desarrollar
parkinson también con los desafíos
mentales que esto supone para las
personas bien dejaban de hacer estos
relojes un simple accesorio para
convertirse en una herramienta vital por
decirlo así Natalia vamos a cambiar de
tema y vamos a Nigeria donde algunas
personas están utilizando el baile
concretamente la salsa para hacer frente
a los problemas mentales sí se trata de
una iniciativa local que desarrolló un
fotógrafo y bailarín que se llama MK
adindu esta persona luchó durante años
contra depresión ansiedad y otros
problemas mentales después de haber sido
víctima de abuso sin embargo encontró en
la salsa Un refugio y ahora comparte en
la capital del país
clases da clases para que otras personas
que también padecen este tipo de
problemas puedan ayudar a luchar contra
sus dolencias veamos su testimonio
la salsa Era lo único que podía hacerme
sonreír todos esos días que estuve
batallando peleando con Mis demonios con
mi pasado con mi todo cuando bailas con
alguien no hay espacio para que pienses
en tus penas
Natalia también está tipo de soluciones
muchas veces ponen en evidencia la
debilidad de los sistemas sanitarios de
estos países para hacer frente a las
dolencias mentales de sus residentes si
Andrés esto es un peligro concretamente
en países como Nigeria donde la
estigmatización de las personas que
padecen problemas de Salud Mental es muy
alta y también entre la población existe
un gran desconocimiento de las causas
que
generan este tipo de dolencias
concretamente un estudio sondeo
realizado en 2019 por el instituto de
encuestas de África determinó que hasta
un 55% de la población
cree que los problemas mentales
tienen determinados por que su origen se
debe a espíritus malignos que poseen a
las personas expertos de Salud Mental
justamente alertan sobre este tipo de
concepciones entre la población veamos
no es un problema espiritual es un
problema de salud la gente siempre
identifica fácilmente la salud física
está bien Tengo malaria tengo diabetes
hipertensión creo que es normal pero
luego cuando se trata de que su cerebro
está enfermo comienzan a encontrar otra
forma de explicarlo en lugar de saber
que es una enfermedad más
bueno para terminar hemos hecho un poco
un recuento de cómo está la situación de
Salud Mental en el país de acuerdo a un
informe de unicef uno de cada seis
nigerianos entre entre 15 y 24 años
padece algún tipo de
padecimiento de Salud Mental como
ansiedad u otros problemas de salud Cabe
destacar también que en todo el país hay
trescientos psiquiatras es decir una
media de un psiquiatra por cada 700.000
habitantes si miramos las cifras por
ejemplo de Estados Unidos es un
psiquiatra por cada 11.000 habitantes en
total hay ocho hospitales en todo el
país que hacen frente no solamente a
formar a Los profesionales para todos
estos habitantes sino también a hacer
frente a los pacientes que
requieren algún tipo de tratamiento
hospitalización y finalmente destaquemos
que existe una ley se llama
concretamente la ley de la locura que
Data de 19 58 y esta ley pone en riesgo
a los pacientes debido a que da la
potestad a los médicos de enviar a la
cárcel a las personas que padecen algún
problema de Salud Mental tratandolos de
esta forma como criminales Y además
impidiendo que puedan acceder a algún
tipo de tratamiento para este tipo de
problemas como vemos Andrés es una
situación bastante compleja en este país
africano y las autoridades
internacionales de salud piden que se
desarrolle no solamente políticas para
ampliar este cubrimiento de salud sino
que también se modifiquen las leyes y es
una situación que viven también varios
países Natalia y precisamente algo que
nos dejó la pandemia fue ese llamado a
prestarle más atención a la Salud Mental
correcto Andrés Así es Muchas gracias
Natalia por este informe nos vemos
entonces en una próxima oportunidad
Muchas gracias